Dany: Do you worry that a lot of the work
that was done after 9/11 is coming undone?
Cheney: I worry that a lot of it's been set
aside by the Obama Administration and now
15 years later, it's become fashionable in
some circles, including sometimes on the Hill
with some of my own Republican friends, that
we've forgotten or choose to set aside the
events of 9/11. When you have 19 guys armed
with airline tickets and box cutters come
to the United States, hijack aircraft, kill
3,000 of our people, take down the World Trade
Center, blow a hole in the Pentagon, would
have taken out probably the White House or
the Capitol Building if it hadn't been for
the passengers on United 93, that's a history-altering
event. It's an act of war. It's worse than
Pearl Harbor.
And yet here we are 15 years later and people
are sort of thinking, "Well, that was a one-off
affair," or we can afford to get rid of the
database we built with the terror surveillance
program, turn it all over to the companies,
and ease off on the policies we put in place
that I believe prevented further attacks.
And it's unfortunate. It's as though we're
going to have to get to the point where we
have another attack before everybody's ready
to really buckle down again and do those things
that are necessary to keep us safe.
Dany: So one of the things that was said at
the end of the Bush Administration was the
policies that you put in place are succeeding
and the evidence of that is there hasn't been
another attack.
Cheney: Right.
Dany: And there hasn't been certainly another,
there have been attempts in the United States.
Cheney: Right.
Dany: There have also been some lone wolf
or self-starter terrorist attacks, but there
hasn't actually been an attack. Is that a
testimony to the capabilities of the intelligence
community, a testimony to the incapabilities
of the terrorist group? How do you see that?
Because I think that might be what President
Obama would say. "What's your evidence?"
Cheney: Yeah. Well, we had a report even,
for example, right after 9/11 that Al Qaeda
was in Pakistan. Excuse me. We had evidence
right after 9/11 that Al Qaeda was seeking
a nuclear device in Pakistan, where they have
nuclear devices. We had to be concerned from
the very beginning about those kinds of things
and we had reporting about attacks that never
came off, attack on the highest building on
the West Coast of the United States, attack
in downtown London.
So it's clear that what we did, the terrorist
surveillance program and so-forth, did put
in place the necessary steps. The fact of
that we didn't get hit again I really think
has a lot to do with the vigilance, with the
airline security measures we put in place,
we had attacks fail such as the underwear
bomber over Detroit. So there's no doubt in
my mind it was a positive, successful policy.
And so the notion that Barack Obama brought
to office was that first of all, that we'd
over-stepped the bounds. Remember when he
went to Cairo and he apologized to the Muslim
world for our over-reaction to 9/11. One thing
that I found out later was that if you look
at some of the documents that were released
when Snowden stole documents, that we uncovered
when Liz and I were doing our latest book
was that our ambassador to Japan had sent
a cable back to the White House during that
first year when Obama was doing his apology
tour saying the Japanese had rejected his
request that he be allowed to go to Hiroshima
and apologize for our having dropped the bomb
on Hiroshima to end World War II.
So he set a tone out there that...and a set
of policies, including what he's done to defense...that
have persuaded a lot of our friends and allies
around the world that they can no longer count
on the United States. That we don't have their
back. And I think it shows in terms of the
relationships we have with so many of those
folks that the United States is no longer
looked to as the go-to people to deal with
the terrorist problem.
Dany: I want to come back to the question
of defense quickly in a minute, but let me
ask you about the Middle East. It is not the
place it was in 2008 when you and President
Bush left office. There are conflicts from
Yemen to Syria to Lebanon to Iraq to Libya,
throughout North Africa. Al Qaeda is really
back and many suggest it's as strong as it
was on September 10th, 2001. What do you see
as the root of those conflicts? Do you think
the United States bears any responsibility
for that?
Cheney: I don't. I think some people have
suggested our actions in effect promoted or
generated 9/11. That's hogwash. We were not
doing anything that merited that attack. It
was the terrorists themselves who decided
they wanted to hit the United States. The
Mideast has been a place for conflict for
a long time. When I was Secretary of Defense,
Saddam Hussein invaded Kuwait and we had to
do Desert Storm. But at the time, we were
able to organize the entire region in order
to prevail, if you will. It was a great coalition
put together. We had a $60 billion war that
cost us 5 billion because others chipped in.
It was a unique moment when you pull all of
that together and when the U.S. was clearly
preeminent in the region.
Since then, over time obviously there have
been the rise of ISIS, the development of
efforts to establish a caliphate, which they've
successfully done now in Syria and Iraq. We've
seen efforts by the Iranians to dominate.
They now are sort of preeminent if you will
in Beirut, in Damascus, in Yemen. The IRGC
has been very, very active over the years.
The Iranians have been very active over the
years pursuing the title they bear as the
world's worst state sponsor of terror. And
all of that's been going on now for a long
time before we got involved.
Dany: So one argument I often have with people
in Washington is about whether the Iraq war
was a triggering factor. There's a suggestion
that a lot of people like to make...and it's
not really a partisan suggestion, more of
an ideological one...that getting rid of Saddam
Hussein just sort of ripped the lid off the
Middle East and it was from thence that everything
began to domino, topple regimes, the Arab
Spring. What do you say to that?
Cheney: Well, I say you've got to look back
at history. We had a very serious nuclear
proliferation problem in the Middle East that
goes back to 1981. Long before we did anything
vis-à-vis Saddam Hussein but in '81, he had
a nuclear program, the Osirak reactor outside
Baghdad. The Israelis took it out. When I
was secretary of defense in the summer of
'90, I was visited by my Israeli counterpart,
the Defense Minister, Moshe Arens, and the
Senior Uniformed Officer, Ehud Barak, and
they showed me evidence that Saddam had started
up in 1990 a nuclear program again and that
it was pretty far along.
In Desert Storm, we went in, we took out that
program. The IAEA went in afterwards and did
an investigation and found out that he was
much closer than we thought to actually having
nuclear capability. This was an independent,
international atomic energy agency that went
in and checked that. That's not something
the United States came up with and that was
before we ever got into the WMD debate with
respect to when we went in in 2003. It's a
long history of Saddam Hussein trying to develop
weapons of mass destruction. The first intelligence
report I saw after I got elected vice president
in 2000 warned about Iraq and WMD.
So the activities of Saddam Hussein overwhelmingly
created ferment and turmoil and raised the
specter, especially the link between terror
on the one hand and weapons of mass destruction
on the other. He used chemical weapons against
thousands of his own people at Halabja in
1988. I mean, he had a well-established track
record that he was a troublemaker and he had
invaded Kuwait before and we did go in with
the support of a lot of Democrats in '03 and
we achieved our objective in that we got rid
of Saddam Hussein.
That also precipitated other activities. We
found out, for example, that Muammar Qaddafi
had a nuclear program and five days after
we captured Saddam Hussein, he surrendered
all of his nuclear materials to us. His centrifuges,
uranium feed stock, weapons design.
So the circumstances over there in terms of
the problems and the difficulties that were
developing pointed in the direction of what
was my biggest fear, which was the possibility
that terrorists would ultimately acquire something
far deadlier than airline tickets and box
cutters and would acquire a nuclear weapon
or chemicals or a biological agent. I was
quoted in an interview I did about five months
before 9/11 that that was out biggest threat
and I think it still is today. And we've still
got a very serious nuclear proliferation problem
now that goes back over 30 years.
Dany: Right. And the Iranians of course are
unleashed at this point.
Cheney: The Iranians are unleashed. I don't want to spend all your time on
the subject, but we had in 1987, Mr. A.Q.
Khan, who put together the Pakistani program
in a hotel in Dubai, sold the Iranians the
basic plans for centrifuges for $3 million.
Nineteen eighty-seven.
Dany: Right.
Cheney: We found, of course, on our watch
when Meir Dagan showed up, the Israeli head
of Mossad, that Syria had a nuclear reactor
that had been built for them by the North
Koreans. The Israelis took it out in the fall
of '07. What's worked in that part of the
world for dealing with the nuclear problem
has been military force or the threat of military
force. And the thing about the Obama Administration
is they didn't pursue that option. Obama wrote
it off from the very beginning. What they
did was try to bribe the Iranians into being
good guys and giving up their program, but
the net result of that was to provide them
with $150 billion of money that they can spend
on supporting terror.
We have altered our policies I think during
the Obama Administration in major ways to
appease the Iranians, when strength and the
possible use of force has been the key in
the past. But it hasn't been used in this
administration at all and I think that's to
the detriment of our interest.
Dany: The perception in the region certainly
is that we are looking at the region through
the prism of Tehran. I agree with you about
that. There are candidates for president and
members of Congress, Republicans and Democrats,
who have suggested that the Middle East was
better off and that the world was better off
with not just Saddam Hussein in power but
Saddam Hussein and Bashar al-Assad and the
strong men who really characterized the Middle
East for the last half-century.
Cheney: Right.
Dany: What do you say to that?
Cheney: Well, that may make sense 50 years
ago. You wanted to get behind your oceans
and be safe and sound and comfortable. But
in my mind all of that ended when terrorist
organizations were able to use those territories
as a base of operation to train and equip
the attack of 9/11.
When 19 guys can show up over here with airline
tickets and box cutters and kill 3,000 of
our people and blow up the World Trade Center,
the idea that you can let that set of whatever
you want to call them, dictators...point is
that Afghanistan for example had become a
safe harbor for Al Qaeda. And Syria now is
a safe harbor for ISIS. We know they're trying
to attack us, they want to hit us in the homeland.
They've already launched attacks that have
threatened us and our friends and allies.
Bombing the buses in London, for example,
or what happened in France a short time ago.
And they've done it here in the United States.
And so the notion that we can allow somebody
like Saddam Hussein or a situation that's
happened in Libya, that it's perfectly okay
what they're doing, they can't reach us, they
can't hurt us. And that's just not true. Muammar
Qaddafi obviously got religion when we took
down Saddam Hussein. If we hadn't done that,
if he'd been allowed to develop his nuclear
program, then he was overthrown by ISIS, then
the debate would be, well, who's got the nukes?
Has ISIS inherited them from the old regime?
Same thing in Syria. If the Israelis hadn't
taken out that North Korean-built reactor
in Syria, then today that area, Al-Khabar
in Eastern Syria occupied by ISIS, they would
also now be the proud owners of the nuclear
reactor. So developments on the ground over
there are I think ultimately a direct threat
to the United States, to the safety and survival
of the United States. The technology has developed.
We are vulnerable to those organizations as
long as they have access to safe harbors and
sanctuary, as long as they have the ability
to acquire deadlier weapons.
Pakistan has a nuclear program, has had for
years, but out of Pakistan emerged A.Q. Khan.
He set up his own black market operation.
Libya was his biggest customer after we got
Qaddafi's materials, then we went and took
down A.Q. Khan. He's under house arrest, has
been in Pakistan. But he has testified in
the newspapers, in a newspaper story to the
effect that the North Koreans now have state-of-the-art
centrifuge technology. Where'd they get it?
They got it from Pakistan.
So you've already got sort of the seed of
very destructive capabilities that could be
used against the United States or our friends
and allies. It's there. It's in the Middle
East. There was one report that the Iranians
paid for the last ballistic missile test by
the North Koreans.
So the ability for us to say, "Well, it's
okay if Saddam stays in power..." He's going
to mess with weapons of mass destruction and
he had before. You can argue about how much
was there when we went in in '03 but there's
no question he had been involved previously,
that he's had them and used them. Or the Libyan
program or the Iranian program or the Pakistani
program.
It's a place we have to be involved. We're
far beyond the point when you could look at
it as a remote part of the world and it's
all right if there's some dictator over there
mistreating his people. It's about our safety
and survival as a nation.
Dany: Was it a mistake for the United States
and NATO to help take out Muammar Qaddafi?
Cheney: I wasn't involved at that point. I'd
left the government and so I don't know everything
there is to know about it. Qaddafi had, to
some extent, come around in the sense that
he had surrendered his nuclear materials to
us. And I, just as not having been part of
the process, I'm reluctant to pass judgment
on it. I think the follow-through obviously
has been the destruction of Qaddafi and his
regime and ISIS now has a significant presence
in Libya and that's right across the Med from
Italy and Europe. But not having been part
of the debate internally I just...I can't
make that judgment.
Dany: I have to comment too that it is ironic
to me that a government that rose to power
on the back of criticism of the Iraq war and
how the aftermath was carried out, walked
away from Libya as if there were no lessons
from the Iraq war.
Cheney: Right.
Dany: It is fascinating. So just to...Russia
is now in Syria. Vladimir Putin has taken
the Crimea. We seem to have forgotten about
it as a nation already. They're in Donetsk,
they're in Luhansk. There's some suspicion
they may even go into some of our NATO-allied
countries. Are we handling Putin correctly?
Cheney: I don't think so. I think Putin believes
he's got a window here that runs to the end
of the Obama Administration. We've seen him
move on to Crimea as you pointed out, in the
Ukraine, now he's in Syria. It's as though
he is trying to recreate elements of the old
Soviet Empire that came apart back in '90
and '91.
I think he also has aspirations on the Baltics.
I think he'd like nothing better than to be
able to put pressure on the Baltics. Not so
much directly by military action, but they
all get all of their energy supplies, their
gas all comes from Russia. They were all part
of Russia at one time. The Russians appear
to be spending money on trying to influence
the internal politics of the Baltics.
So if he could stir up enough trouble, I could
see him trying to put pressure on the Baltics
that they either have to do what he wants
them to do, probably withdraw from NATO, or
some additional pressures will be brought
to bear on the Baltics. I think that's his
real objective. Now will he pull it off? I
don't know and I question at this point how
determined NATO would in fact be without strong
U.S. leadership. We provide 75% of the funding
for NATO and the defense budgets here in the
U.S. have been cut dramatically. That's provided
a rationale for the Europeans to go forward and
cut their defense budgets as well. So it's
worrisome.
Dany: It's not just the Democrats who cut defense
budgets.
Cheney: Right.
Dany: Republicans and Democrats came together.
We've lost a trillion dollars over 10 years
in defense spending. Why?
Cheney: Well, because Congress couldn't get
its act together back in, what was it, 2011.
Passed the Budget Control Act in 2011. But
that basically imposed and set up a mechanism
through sequestration that in effect says
if Congress doesn't get budgets passed and
adopted, then the meat axe falls. The sequester
takes place.
And what's happened now is instead of the
traditional way of doing business in the Defense
Department...where you look at the world,
identify threats, figure out what we need
in order to counter those threats or to cope
with them and then ask for the amount of money
that's involved...we don't do that anymore.
Now what happens is the inability to come
to an agreement has led to the frequent use
of the sequester.
The Defense Department makes up about 17%
of the budget. It takes 50% of the cuts because
a lot of the domestic programs have been exempted
from sequester. So the bottom line is that
Congress...and some of it on a partisan basis,
some of it on a bipartisan basis, there is
no question that there was Republican support
for this particular solution...but what it's
done over time is, this is four or five years
now since we put defense budgets together
the way they ought to be put together, in
relation to the threat. We're now in a situation
where our capabilities are significantly diminished.
Ray Odierno, when he stepped down as the Army
chief last fall, said that the United States
Army is less ready today than any time in
its history. That goes back over 200 years.
It's a very, very dangerous situation in the
sense that we've conveyed to our friends that
we don't want to act on their behalf. We conveyed
to others, including some of our adversaries,
that we don't have the capability to act effectively.
We've changed.
If you look at the strategic concept that
always drove our planning in the past while
I was there...of course that was a long time
ago...but that we believed we needed to have
the capacity to fight two wars simultaneously
and enough left over to deal with other things
on the side. That's gone. Our forces are so
much lower, so much less ready.
Other things that are problems, we're not
investing as much as we need to in order to
counter the capabilities that are developed
by the Chinese and the Russians. The Russians
are modernizing their strategic forces. The
Chinese are as well. The Chinese have developed
the capability to take down satellites. They've
got a ballistic missile that will take out
an aircraft carrier with a conventional warhead.
They've taken the Sai Islands in the South
China Sea, built military bases there. The
Russians now are flying provocative missions
over parts of NATO territory and along borders
with NATO.
There's a major shift in the sense, in terms
of how they look at the United States. They
don't fear us any more. And I think that leads
them probably to underestimate or perhaps
overestimate how far they can go, but underestimate
what's sensitive for us. The world was very
safe and stable when the U.S. was the principal
power, when we had the military capability
to deal with any contingency and we were prepared
to use it when we felt the need. I don't think
that's the case anymore.
Another point that's crucial is our military
advantage for a long time really since the
end of World War II has been based on our
technological edge. We were the first ones
with stealth, we were the first ones with
precision guided munitions, we had...remember
Desert Storm and the tremendous capabilities
we demonstrated. Nobody could match that.
That day's passed.
The Chinese are moving aggressively to close
some of those gaps. The Russians are, too.
Or find ways around it so they come up with
countermeasures that are effective against
our armed forces. The whole area of cyber-warfare's
enormously important. And I worry that we're
not doing enough there and the Chinese have
gotten very good at it. So have the Russians.
Perhaps Al Qaeda or ISIS. And that capacity
to hack into our system. They've demonstrated
it by taking the personnel records of those
of us who worked for the federal government.
I mean, it's not personal.
Dany: Right.
Cheney: But they've done it. And when you
think about the vulnerability of our system,
our reliance on technology, the extent to
which they could hack into our power grid
or other key elements of our infrastructure
is very real. And we are not doing what we
need to be doing because of budget cuts in
order to maintain our advantage and guarantee
our safety.
Dany: You just in 30 seconds laid out an enormously
compelling case that the United States needs
to show leadership, that the United States
needs to reinvest, not for offense but for
deterrence. What's happened to Congress? What's
happened to the Republican Party?
Cheney: Well, I don't want to blame everybody
in the Republican Party obviously. A lot of
it is you haven't had any presidential leadership
in this area. He's been going the other way.
He loves the sequester that frees up resources
that he can use for his domestic programs.
As I say, a lot of the domestic programs have
been exempted from the sequester.
The whole process of putting together budgets
has broken down and I think one of the keys
for us has to be...and I've argued this with
my friends periodically, they ask me to come
up and chat on different matters, which I'm
always happy to do...but we have to recognize
that our number one priority as a nation,
as a government, has to be defense. That's
more important than anything else. If you
can build nice highways, that's fine. You've
got infrastructure you've got to worry about.
We've got a lot of things the government does
and that we want to have done, but nothing's
more important than the safety and security
of the American people. And right now that's
being short-changed.
Dany: There's no substitute for leadership.
Cheney: Exactly right.
Dany: It's always such a pleasure. Thank you
very much.
Cheney: Thanks, Dany. Enjoyed it.